Okay,
you're going to get more numbers today.
I know how many love numbers you can't live without numbers.
So
what did I tell you was the traditional before modern times death rate number
you should keep or birth rate.
Same
about per thousand.
About 40 to 50 per thousand is the birth and death rate at a,
at a,
at a life expectancy of 20 years.
That means one 20th of the people die every year.
And so you need 50 out of a thousand births,
one 20th of your people to be brought.
So births and deaths in what we call primitive times,
which might mean up to the Napoleonic revolution almost,
uh,
is 40 to 50
births and 40 to 50 deaths a year.
So now here is modern times.
We're starting in 1950 and all of these graphs and coming up in a,
in the period of the puppet,
the main it beginning burst of the population explosion,
1950 to 1990 and all these cases,
and here are the various parts of the world.
And you'll notice that this is the death,
the,
I'm sorry,
the birth rate is 50,
birth rate is 43 or something,
(424) 034-0540 five that by at 1950,
the birth rate is it approximately it's level for centuries,
uh,
way back.
And we know that not too much before this time,
since population was not growing until some,
a little bit before this time that the death rate must have been the same.
So the death rate was also 40 to 50 people.
But look with hadn't by 1950,
the death rate is already down to half of its traditional level.
Even in sub Saharan Africa,
it's almost reduced to half.
And in Central America,
the Caribbean,
uh,
less than half South America,
less than half China,
about half South Asia,
about half Southeast Asia,
about half.
So in most of the world,
by the 1950s,
uh,
the birth rate was still extremely high and put,
the death rate had come down to half of what it had always been.
And what was going on is that these countries,
we're almost all still under colonial rule with the exception of South America.
Uh,
which might be the reason why it's even better.
And among all of their faults,
the colonias did a basic sanitation,
basic public health,
basic public order,
and they stopped a lot of the warfare between communities that they imposed a
lot of violence on the people.
But that was apparently much less than the violence that local communities
imposed upon each other in the precolonial era.
So the death rate was way down by the 1950s,
sometime in the 50s,
around 1950,
the birth rate started coming down in all these countries.
And even though the birth rate starts at these very,
very high levels,
they come down almost everywhere.
We'll of course the exception being sub Saharan Africa,
and you've read about why that is.
And I keep saying that almost everything we say Subsaharan Africa is an
exception to the rate.
So even though the death rate was down,
the birth rate didn't change much.
But in every other of the developing regions of the world,
the birth rate and the death rate came down approximately in parallel with each,
with each other.
And of course the difference between that birth and death rate is a population
population increase.
And this is the,
the hay day of the population explosion.
And remember this is per thousand,
so it's a percent,
uh,
kind of kind of a number.
So as the population grows,
the number of people represented by this percent cap grows and grows and grows.
And so this explains the graph I showed you last time or two times ago,
not again.
So starting again,
1950 to 1990.
There's the number of people added each year,
just keeps growing with one blip.
And you'll see later in the course I've shown you that,
but before we'll discuss what that a blip is.
So the data for the individual regions of the world and this all fits together.
Makes Sense.
Now we've been through the European population story.
And again,
we saw that,
not always,
but mostly the death rate fell first and then the birth rate fell in Europe,
went through a population explosion.
So to say this story,
the way I've been telling you,
no differences that,
that the third world is just going through exactly what Europe,
uh,
went through.
Uh,
but it isn't true.
And let's compare a to of the fertility transition.
This is Sweden,
this is Mexico.
And you'll notice that Sweden has,
you know,
a lot of birth and death kind of hanging around until maybe here until 1860s.
And that's just what the Princeton project out that the really a serious decline
happened somewhere in this 1870 region.
And then
just fix this and then the death rate declines rather continuously on through
the time and the birth rate declined.
So this starts around 1870.
Mexico's decrease starts around 1970.
So between what we now call the developing countries of the third world
countries,
about a hundred year difference,
uh,
between when Europe started its transition and when the developing countries
started their transition.
Now,
a hundred years may seem a lot to you when the course of human history,
since these,
these numbers had been going on forever,
uh,
a hundred years is a very,
very short time.
Another difference you should know is,
oh man,
hang on.
I just fixed this.
Usually that's all that's required,
I hope.
Nope,
it makes it worse.
Decent backwards.
Anybody have a laser point by any miracle?
All right,
we're going to have a little bit of trouble today,
but I think you can,
you can figure things out.
So notice that the levels of,
of everything there are lower in Sweden,
that Sweden starts in the European hundred generally start at a lower level of
births and a lower level of deaths.
So they already,
by the time that they're serious transition starts,
they are already quite a ways down compared to where Mexico starts.
Notice that the deaths and the births are much higher in Mexico than in Europe.
Oh,
wonderful.
Wonderful,
wonderful,
wonderful.
Ha.
Lifesaver.
Okay.
So now that those,
those are important,
but notice the gradual illness of the decline here,
that Sweden had a long time to adjust to these changes.
Whereas look at the drop in death rate in Mexico.
Boom.
Basically all of a sudden,
and then give it a generation.
Look at the drop in the birth rate.
That's the most amazing thing.
How rapidly things change in the developing world compared to the way it changed
in,
in Europe.
So,
and because of this rapidity of this decline and a natural delay here,
whereas in Sweden,
that might be the delay.
The delay means because of the repetitive,
the client that the difference now between births and deaths is this huge amount
compared to a much smaller amount here.
Europe never had to cope with the rate of increase,
the number of people added every year.
The percentage of population never had to cope with anything like what the
currently developing countries have.
And that's a result of,
of,
of the,
the,
the rapid,
uh,
graph.
The other thing to note of course is that,
uh,
by this time,
the births and the deaths and Sweden are essentially equal and Sweden's
population is not growing anymore and that as you heard from professor conductor
title Bounce Lecture is characteristic of Europe as a whole as well as Japan.
Uh,
east a lot of the East Asian countries.
So,
uh,
a cartoon of this which has won a lot writing about it.
And one big thing wrong with it is that here's the rich countries they start,
this is the,
this is the rate of increase of population growth that they start earlier.
Uh,
he starts at quite early in France and a hundred years later that what's in this
graph is called poor countries start the peak,
the raw,
the rises slow,
the fall is slow,
the rise is fast,
the fall as fast.
The peak is much lower.
Here the peak is about 1%.
The maximum rate of growth that Europe ever experienced is,
was 1%.
Whereas for poor countries,
the average was two and a half percent and some were up at 3%.
So enormously greater stress on the countries that went through this very,
very fast.
And
why,
why did this happen?
Why is it so much faster in developing country?
And we see that that as each country,
as it gets in to the,
their,
their transition phase later,
everything happens faster.
It's quite a,
quite a robust,
uh,
phenomenon every,
every few years.
Uh,
he say,
Oh man,
China or some country,
you know,
Korea,
Taiwan had the fastest,
uh,
decline ever.
And then a few years later,
some new countries enter in and they've declined as is even faster.
And one of the main reasons is that contraceptives were invented around here,
the pill,
the diaphragm kind of all of that.
Well,
some of them went way back here.
But the modern method,
the really modern methods,
we're all like the pill in around the 1960s and this is a graph showing that the
developing countries are using contraception.
So here is contraceptive prevalence.
The percent of women in childbearing ages that use contraception and it ranges
from very little less than 10% to like 70%.
The US is in this 60 to 70% range.
And notice that the fertility,
the total fertility rate,
the country's not using contraception,
very high fertility rate as they use more and more,
uh,
contraception,
their fertility rate goes on.
So the mechanism in the developing countries is use of contraception and mostly
modern contraception.
Whereas in Europe went through its transition.
They didn't have hardly any contraception,
some condoms were just beginning to come in,
but none of the modern chemical methods or the better kinds of barrier methods.
So this,
the story is kind of a,
that why the developing countries are faster,
is that the science is already there.
The medical,
uh,
stuff is there to,
the death rate comes down because again,
Europe developed,
uh,
the medical knowhow and then it just got transferred very rapidly.
Vaccines,
vitamins,
uh,
viruses,
all of those were discovered before the transition there.
And just as important as,
uh,
the knowledge was an attitude towards civil government and civil society,
that it is the responsibility of governments to take care of the health of their
people.
That's not a given.
Most countries through most of history,
the government was a rapacious and their idea was to get as much taxes from the
peasants as possible.
The peasants were sort of like non humans and use those taxes to have an army
and go try to get enlarge their territories.
The idea of civil government where the government is for the people is a fairly
modern idea and one of the basic things that governments try to do is,
is public health.
Then of course the uh,
the,
in the technology,
look at the contraceptives,
I've mentioned the means of mass communication.
I'll show you a slide later.
That change in behavior is in Inco is triggered by a lot by what you see on
television,
what you see in the radio,
what you see in newspapers.
Uh,
as in chimpanzees,
we're very social species and we're always looking what's acceptable,
what kind of behavior is acceptable and gossip.
Maybe I mentioned this,
that most of what humans say to each other as gossip and the function of gossip
is defined.
What are the limits of acceptable behavior.
So the mass media is extremely important in this and like telling people in this
case that two children is,
that is the proper way of families.
They see American television,
American movies or Japanese and uh,
what do they see rich people with two children,
whereas they previously believed that,
you know,
in order to be rich in some sense you have to have eight children.
So the media are very important in changing perceptions.
Also for a very long time,
maybe not now,
the West had a cache had,
was considered the future of the modernity.
The West was very respected and loved around the world.
And so the use the small family norm,
uh,
was,
a characteristic of the western.
A lot of people try to become like the west.
There was that cache and of course family planning programs.
The West had a long experience with family planning programs.
You've read some of the markets,
Sanger stuff from America,
the Marie stopes stuff from England where people are struggling with these
things and finally come out the other end and decide to gain control of their
fertility.
So in a sense,
both medically and culturally,
Westerners were the Guinea pigs for this,
uh,
fertility transition.
And then once it was,
in some sense perfected and finished in the west,
it was sort of transferred wholesale to the newly developing countries.
Now another thing about the fertility transition is that not only is it more
intense a demographically with all the statistics that we can gather,
but it's also more intense emotionally.
So as you're for sure,
well aware by now in this course,
that there's enormously strong social norms about sex and reproduction.
And if those norms are about to change and attacks one of the most important
foundations of a culture,
and there's not,
that does not happen without a lot of conflict within the culture.
And so in the west,
although there's lots of discussion about this,
the idea of individualism,
that people individually go out and do what's good for them,
they make choices based on their own desires.
There's kind of a long history of that.
And it was sort of formalized by Adam Smith in economic saying that if everybody
went out and tried to get as rich as possible,
it'd be wonderful for everybody.
In most of the developing countries,
they have a more communal kind of attitude.
Whereas often if you speak to older,
say Chinese or Indians who the smallest unit of desire,
which they speak of,
is the family very hard to get them to think of what they want.
It's family or village or some larger entity.
So when you start changing norms,
so there,
the,
the norms in,
in,
in non western societies or,
or pre modern western size are very much stronger in control of the people.
People have less latitude to go and do their own thing.
They,
they're,
they're under social,
much more social,
uh,
control.
And of course all of these things,
multiple square,
these things quadruple them.
Uh,
if you're talking about sex and one of the readings,
I don't know if you gonna do it tonight or you did it or write about the
Palestinian woman who was killed.
Did you,
was that not in your,
not in your reading yet.
So what it is that a Palestinian woman was suspected of.
Some infidelity,
no,
no hard evidence for it.
And her little and her little brother killed her after searching for her for
many years.
And the idea of giving you that article is,
it's,
it's a tear jerker,
but it gives you an idea of the emotionality of the,
the,
uh,
the strength with which the older social norms are held.
And someone who appears on the surface even mildly to violate it,
uh,
um,
can eat,
can get killed.
And a Jordanian woman,
uh,
road has just come out with a book 2003 on her lost.
And she talked about her best friend.
And this is what triggered her to patent is right the back.
This woman,
her friend had been seen in public walking with a man who's not a relative,
not doing anything bad,
but right there in public.
So,
you know,
nothing was going on,
uh,
on the streets.
And this being seen alone,
being seen on the streets of the man who was not a relative with such a stain on
the family's honor that the woman's father stabbed her 12 times in the chest and
then stood over the body to make sure that she was dead before calling an
ambulance.
So imagine this,
the strength of the cultural norms that allows him a brother to kill a sister,
a father to kill his daughter.
In this last case,
this woman who the father killed her,
uh,
the family was not poor and was not Muslim even though it's in Jordan,
but they were middle class and Roman Catholic.
So that means it's not almost nobody in these cultures escapes the cultural
norms.
Even though,
uh,
Catholics and Jordan are,
are very small.
Minority has his,
uh,
middle class in Jordan.
They obey the same rules of the culture as everyone else.
And the author of that book claims that this happens to thousands of women,
that there's thousands of women dying and honored so called honor killings.
Now,
of course,
it's not restricted to the Middle East.
You will read a little bit later or reading,
uh,
for India where a woman is raped by her father in law and her own father insists
on killing her.
That's from India.
And you have to contrast this with not all cultures are,
are like this.
So contrast this very tight,
strict norm about,
uh,
women's giving woman any possibility for going beyond the norm.
Compare it with the na of China,
which I think you've already read where everything is totally free or the
Japanese,
the story that the Cmr,
so you're Maura women.
Have you read that yet?
You know,
we're,
again,
there's a huge amount of sexual freedom.
So it isn't that all cultures have the same,
uh,
cultural norms,
but they all do have cultural norms and violation of those cultural norms,
uh,
will be punished.
Another thing is that in the difference between the western and the eastern
fertility transition is that the economic constraints,
the,
the level of poverty,
uh,
in the third world is,
is much worse than it was in Europe at the time of its transition.
So there's just,
everything is more difficult when you're poor and you're living in a poor
country with poorly developed government,
everything is more difficult.
And in your reading packet is a one,
a one page,
a collection of headlines from Tanzania and you just see all the problems that
Tanzania is going through,
uh,
in a period when uh,
their fertility is high and maybe beginning to start falling down.
Okay.
So we have some understanding of the many ways in which,
uh,
statistically,
except by magnitude the fertility of the demographic transition in the countries
that have entered it,
it since 1960 looks very different from those that entered it in 1860
quantitatively.
Also,
when you go through a period of population growth,
the question is,
well,
how much did your population grow all together between the beginning of the
transition,
which we've had the beginning in Europe in the end in Europe as your tech says
something like 19 seven,
1870 to 1930 and,
uh,
Europe,
grew by about a factor of four.
Uh,
the population quadrupled.
This is the time when the population of the developing countries with staying
constants.
But developing countries,
India actually as far as we can predict as having one of the smallest between
four and five.
So they're sort of at the maximum,
uh,
for Europe,
no country in Europe was more than four.
In India,
one of the lowest countries for the developing world will be somewhere between
four and five.
So we expect Mexico will have grown by a factor of seven to 10 times Kenya by
more than 15 times.
So here's again,
countries that started the transition poor.
Uh,
they're still moderately poor.
Mexico is doing better,
but,
uh,
certainly Kenya's not in India is doing somewhat better and now they have to
cope with five,
six,
seven,
eight,
nine,
10 times as much population
because of these multipliers.
The fraction of people in the different parts of the world goes first one way
and first the other way.
Uh,
before the,
uh,
the mortality transition,
Europeans represented about 18% of the world's population at its maximum when
you're up,
had the maximum Frankie Europe and European people in America,
Australia,
New Zealand and so forth.
But European stock people,
uh,
their fraction,
the European fraction of the world population doubled more than doubled actually
from about doubled from 18 to 35%.
So they,
Europe was undergoing Europeans who are undergoing a huge population thing,
but now a monotonal by 1995 because Europe's population growth is over,
European peoples are over.
And the developing countries population growth is starting.
It's back to where it started.
It's back to about 18%.
And now that's 1995.
And we've had already 13 years of,
uh,
population growth continuing in the developing countries.
And it's continuing and,
uh,
getting more and more so the,
the relative percentage of people in what's now called the developing world
versus the European world,
uh,
is going now to be so high,
in the developing countries that it's way beyond anything that was historically
the case,
except maybe when humans started moving out of Africa into,
uh,
the Middle East and into Europe.
So,
and this may not stable.
I mean,
so far there is no sign that European population of almost all of the European
population is now have fertility rates below two.
And,
uh,
so they are going to,
if they continue with that of course they eventually disappeared altogether.
And the idea that there's going to be some stabilization of some ratio of say
rich and poor countries,
uh,
is,
is dependent on fertility coming up in the developed countries.
And we don't have any reason to expect that.
And this is an important factor because if part of live of,
of the,
the developing countries coming out of poverty and is aid from the west and
that's again a very,
everything is debated,
debatable in this course.
How much help aid a does it actually,
there's no question about that.
In some cases it's tremendously helpful that if there's nobody left in the
developed countries to,
to give them,
give the aid,
then one of the props which helps develop in countries come up,
uh,
we'll have disappeared.
Okay.
So we've gone through the quantities of the transition,
but you've competed,
we have compared the,
the demographic transition developing countries with European countries,
but we haven't compared it to anything else.
And so,
uh,
the world populations that I've say is growing something like 70,
80,
70 to 80 million people a year.
And the question is,
if we imagine some sort of a landing for this,
what kinds of things are going to stop this population explosion?
And there's bad things and there's good things and possibility,
bad possibilities and good possibilities.
So the bad possibilities and have been known for,
you know,
have been thought about for a long time.
It's one famine that could,
people could start storming disease aids.
People are talking about aids balancing the popular education or war.
So I'm going to give you some idea of the magnitude of these factors.
So family,
uh,
one way that famine operates is some country has a big drought and they go
through a short period of terrible famine,
but that's not the main thing.
People all over the world and especially children are malnourished and
malnourished lists,
lists,
leads to disease.
So,
uh,
it's very hard to get these statistics and to gather the statistics and it
depends on who you're talking to.
So I was teaching in a health course and the,
we sort of did a cereal lecturers and Michelle barrier,
um,
professor of international infectious diseases,
uh,
gave the lecture before mine.
So I went to her lecture to see the lay of the land and she was describing,
you know,
millions of deaths from various diseases and the medical students,
this is to medical center,
had no clue.
And they were just absolutely shocked at that,
the magnitude of what's going on,
especially in developed countries.
And she was listing,
maybe,
you know,
aids is about,
back then it was about 2 million a year.
It might be 3 million and coming down,
uh,
malaria,
tuberculosis from the one to 2 million deaths a year kind of thing,
diarrhea in children,
etc. These are,
there are massive killers in the world.
Next week I came on and said,
you know what,
there's x millions of deaths from malnutrition and there they were shocked cause
it's even bigger number than than Dr. Barry had given.
And so I said,
you know,
what did the same depths you heard about last week?
So the thing is something like,
I don't remember the number of American,
something like if you take a skin test for tuberculosis,
something like a third to a half of us have been exposed to the TB a bug so that
we have antibodies against it.
We basically in some sense in a small sense of had TB,
if you go to India where people have had it,
but the fraction that actually come down and get sick are much,
much higher.
Why malnutrition that all of the diseases,
if you're malnourished,
your immune system and your other body systems can't fight the bug so you
actually get sick and will often die.
So there's a big uh,
uh,
discussion of when you see a deaf to say,
TB.
Is that death caused by the tuberculosis bacillus or is that death caused by
malnutrition and the World Health Organization and a lot of other groups are now
saying that about half the deaths from all of these things are really at a base
caused by malnutrition that at the level of infection,
but that the people are exposed to,
you should see so many deaths.
But you actually see twice that many deaths because,
uh,
people are hungry.
So the numbers from the Food and Agriculture Organization of the United Nations,
or is that 25,000 people die every day?
Like today,
25,000 people will die from starvation or malnutrition.
That's a huge number.
It's 9 million deaths a year.
And so I kind of get out during the course of this lecture of 1,300 people will
die of starvation or malnutrition.
So it's really very serious,
uh,
most of the day.
Yeah.
What,
how many people will be born during this lecture?
[inaudible] also a very large number.
More than the deaths we've seen that the,
you can calculate yourself,
have the,
uh,
the,
the birth rate is something like three times,
two and a half times the death rate,
but that's not just a.com.
You can sort of double the total number of desks will be something a little more
than double the deaths from,
uh,
malnutrition.
So a lot the population is still growing up at as you've seen because we do have
a lot more births than deaths.
I showed you that data before.
So malnutrition is the leading cause of death in children in developing
countries and
mmm,
the numbers you read are all over the place.
And one number that I pulled out as 13 million child deaths a year.
Uh,
and I've seen uh,
lower than that.
Uh,
the World Bank in the middle,
it's millennium goals.
Uh,
you know,
the big millennium goal thing,
what the whole world is supposed to go to says again that half the deaths of
children under five are due to malnutrition and oh,
so this all together for all reasons.
There's 13 million child deaths a year and you get numbers from different sized
anywhere between a third and a half of these deaths are due to malnutrition.
And what is malnutrition look like?
You may have seen,
uh,
this is quite short core.
How many of you heard of that?
It's very prevalent kind of thing too.
I haven't signed in the village.
You go to a village in,
in poor places and you see these distended bellies,
this is
everywhere.
And actually we don't even know even that is a tremendously prevalent thing.
We don't actually know the cause of it.
The old story was that it's a protein deficiency,
disease and protein makes albumin albumin that holds water into the blood and
the tissues.
And when you can't hold water,
it's sort of floods into your tissues and,
and,
and spreads out.
But now there's a lot of other theories and we just don't know really what's the
basic cause of course,
crush your core.
It is malnutrition.
That's,
there's no question about it.
But exactly what in the Diet is,
is missing is not totally clear.
Here's another kind of shocking pan.
Now I'm going to give you some shocking pictures and,
and uh,
uh,
tear jerkers but it's important to see.
It seems saying
this is an American missionary or aid worker.
I don't know which.
And that's her baby.
And that's this baby and they're both six months old
in Africa.
Um,
another thing that happens is that population,
when population grows,
the people who are strongest take the best land and they push people that are
less strong for less population or less violent or whatever reason or less
technologically advanced,
they push them into marginal land like deserts.
And this is the site in Mali of what used to be one of the largest lakes in
Africa.
And then it goes through periodic,
uh,
climatic things.
It dries out every so often.
And so in some sense people should not be living there because you know,
it's going to there,
you know,
goes every so often through droughts,
but they have no choice because stronger peoples in the past have pushed them
into these desert kind of regions.
One of the results of population explosion they've told you in Europe where the
extra farmers had to go up hillsides and into less,
less profitable land.
So there they are in this,
uh,
very arid region and in,
in normal years they can survive but then come to drought and this kind of thing
happens.
And the result,
of course,
this is a,
a boy who is I think nine years old or something.
He's 13 pounds and uh,
almost impossible
to keep the boy alive.
And here's one of the really pictures that,
you know,
in the political discourse about population and fertility and family planning in
America,
there's a lot of motherhood.
You know,
how wonderful motherhood,
everything,
but you have to see,
well,
oops,
okay,
I didn't show that.
I've got,
I put it in the wrong picture,
which is maybe good.
Good for you.
Now you've seen a lot of these pictures.
The organization's I want you to give money,
show a lot of them.
And one of the discussion items about these kinds of pictures is that it makes
people in poor countries seem sort of helpless.
And that's not true.
Then the amount of stuff that people in [inaudible] are doing to try to help
themselves is enormous.
They can be very strong and very smart people,
but the resources are very limited what they can work with.
Okay.
Um,
and so the,
the,
the bottom line of this little bit is that given the number of deaths that we
understand to be from malnutrition and given the number of d of population
increase,
if the solution is to be solved by famine,
if the balancing of births and deaths is going to be a famine situation,
a starvation rate has to increase by a factor of eight,
you know,
plus or minus.
The next thing is a disease is the second of our,
of our triplet of horrible solutions.
And in 2008 it killed about 3 million people up from 2 million.
This is clearly apparently the peak everyone breaking because of the retrovirals
and various other public health measures,
uh,
the number of supposed to go down and the,
the numbers are already changing in the end.
By the end,
at the end of 2007,
the UN got a whole bunch of better data from certain countries and they had to,
they lowered the number of people they thought
to be infected with the AIDS virus by 6.3 million.
So something like 33 million people infected with AIDS.
And presumably they will all die at some point or the other retrovirals can keep
them alive.
Long time notice that 33 million is less than half of one year as population
growth,
uh,
from,
from aids.
And it's the way it works out demographically is here is a somewhat older data
at the from the peak of the,
of the AIDS epidemic.
This is the impact,
uh,
in sub Saharan Africa with and without aids.
So the gray,
uh,
the,
I'm sorry,
the purple is the way the population is.
It was Scott was modeled to increase,
uh,
without aids is if there was no aids.
And then with AIDS,
AIDS kills these people basically prevents these births.
Uh,
you still have an enormous population increase for sub Saharan Africa,
which is the worst effected place.
And this was one of the,
uh,
the worst scenario.
They did a worst scenario run.
They tried to imagine things to be about as bad as they could get.
This thing,
when you do it for a whole,
most of a continent hides a lot of difference.
So this is Uganda,
which has had an intelligent response to AIDS.
And here,
uh,
with AIDS there'll be this much and without aids that would have been this much.
But population keeps growing.
Any case in South Africa,
which is about the worst really badly hit place,
you do see that population growth without aids would be this.
And they're actually expecting population growth to come down as a result of
AIDS.
So in some countries it has a,
an important demographic effect,
but for sub Saharan Africa as a whole,
not an enormous effect in the rest of the world where at least so far the
numbers are much smaller.
Uh,
a minor factor.
It can easily get lost in this statistical noise that we don't know how many
people are in earth.
We don't know exactly how fast the population's growing and AIDS can be within
that statistical noise.
So from a demographic point of view,
uh,
aids as a killer is a significant,
well,
let me show you.
So this is another thing that kills 1.6 million people.
More than half of the AIDS number.
You'll never guess what that is.
It's this,
it's smoked from cooking fires that in the developing countries and the poor
countries,
this is the way people cook and the smoke fills the room,
gets into their lungs and they get all kinds of diseases extra.
And the estimates of that is 1.6 million deaths comparable to tuberculosis and
malaria and somewhat less than aids,
but they have a solution to this loops.
And it's a stove that keeps that,
that you don't get these kinds of smoke with.
And those costs $10 each and they'll cut out a number of desks,
equivalent to half of the AIDS deaths.
So one of the things when,
if you're interested in and understanding the magnitude of the problems of the
world,
one of the things you just have to pay attention to is the magnitude of the
problem and the magnitude of any solution.
And when there's a,
an almost sure thing at $10 available and retroviral rurals costs an awful lot
more,
uh,
you know,
which kind of person are you going to try to save the person that can be saved
by $10 for the person that needs $1,000 to be saved if you have limited kinds of
money.
So,
uh,
from a demographic point of view,
the problem with the almost worst than the total number of deaths,
because you know,
malaria has been people for long time and,
and TB and these are all horrible situation.
Of course,
every death is a horrible sort of thing,
but aids kills people in the prime of their life.
And that's,
this is what we call hollowing out of the age structure.
So there's children who are dependent,
there's adults who work and there's old people who are dependent.
If you kill off your working people,
that leaves the kids with no one to take care of them,
no one to provide economically for them.
That leaves the old people with no one to take care of them.
So an addition.
So the,
the direct deaths from AIDS itself is one horrible thing.
But what they do to taking care of everybody else in the population,
uh,
multiplies than affected by a lot.
And as of 2001,
the last statistic that I could find,
there's about 12 million children that had been orphaned in Africa,
uh,
due to AIDS.
And that is we do a lot of work in the political refugees.
That's tripled the number of political refugees that there are in Africa.
Okay.
So we've done a famine disease and,
and wars is the last set of numbers and you hear it,
cocktail parties at some war or pick whatever the current war is,
you know,
we'll balance births and deaths.
So the worst we've had is the atom bombs.
And underneath your know what the numbers on the atom bombs are.
But the Hiroshima bomb killed 75,000 people.
The Nagasaki Bomb Killed 25,000 people.
That's 100,000 people dead into quick flashes.
But the population on earth grows by approximately 200,000 a day.
So what that means that if we can imagine and all these are imaginary,
if we imagine that some wars are going to balance births and deaths on earth,
that means that every day you have to blow up to Nagasaki bombs and to Hiroshima
bombs killing that equivalent number of people just to keep even,
that doesn't reduce population that just keeps,
uh,
population flat.
It's an idea of giving you all these horrible numbers is just to give you an
idea of the magnitude of,
of,
of this issue and that it's of course,
absolutely unthinkable.
That one sort of continues to just let this pop this situation go rampantly
until one of these negative kind of disasters happens.
There's going to be,
uh,
there's gotta be a solution.
We have to figure it out in some way.
Okay.
So,
so far in the last lecture,
so I've obviously been what we call apocalyptic,
you know,
that the world is coming to an end and due to population explosion,
uh,
but there's a famous saying,
to the opposite,
which is that if something can't go on forever,
it won't.
And I think that,
uh,
has a large chance of happening.
And I,
I've,
I've described some of this already to you last lecture and I'm going to talk
more about it right now.
So consider that these two interviews,
one is an interview very much like the one of the ones in your readings.
It's from Mali in 1983.
Uh,
see Tom,
this is the woman who's heard about contrast on the contraceptive pill but has
not used it.
Interviewer sitaution how many children are more,
would you like to have,
ah,
that is for God to decide.
Interviewer,
you yourself,
how many more children would you like?
How many,
how many children would you like to have in your whole life?
I don't know the number.
It's when God stops my births and interview.
How many boys and how many girls?
Who would you like to have?
It's God that gives me children.
Since it is God that gives or not you,
you cannot make a choice about your children.
You've read some of these.
This is a different country,
a different time.
But this is a not uncommon sort of attitude where people,
you know,
women especially just can't,
it's not within their,
their,
their calculus of conscious choice.
Now in Bangladesh,
which is again,
both of these countries or Muslim Bangladesh shoes,
more,
uh,
conservative,
religiously,
uh,
the poverty getting better now,
but it was about the same.
So these are the d the socio economic indicators for the two countries or about
the same,
but the government in Bangladesh,
uh,
was very different.
And the government of,
from very early on,
uh,
we decided that that they would make family planning available in the country
and the international groups then came on board and said,
okay,
we will help you.
And so this is now another interview with an 18 year old girl named Shemy Ron.
And she is just learning that there is such a thing about her birth control.
And the reason she knows about it is that,
and you'll read about and you're going to read about the family planning program
and the results in Bangladesh is that,
uh,
as I said,
Bangladesh is a very conservative Muslim.
So women are generally not allowed out of the house to get medical service,
for instance.
And so just to go out and talk to women's meetings where these things get
discussed,
no,
they can't do that.
So the family planning program in Bangladesh,
the government program and the,
and the private program hired high class women from that community,
uh,
who themselves were using family planning and,
and Billy and thought it,
it was good and sent them into the houses of poor women who couldn't come out.
This is kind of like if Mohammed the mountain won't come to Muhammad Muhammad
and go,
go to the mountain.
And so the people in the village all know about this woman who will muck Demar.
That was her name and she's considered a health worker.
And she actually gave her aunt,
her aunt was an acceptor and mocked him.
[inaudible] was giving,
came by regularly to give around pills and the girls,
uh,
knew about it,
but they didn't really understand it.
And so they went and asked the aunt,
the girl or Shemy Ron,
uh,
and to the ant refuse to tell her anything because again,
the social conservatism that these matters will be explained to her only when
she's married and she's not to know anything about this now.
So what did the kid do?
Like every kid,
everywhere else in the world,
she goes to school and talks to her friends and then they also pick little bits
of information and misinformation and uh,
pull it together from the other girls.
Some of them apparently knew of McDurmont.
Some of them didn't know about her.
I'm sorry.
I said everyone in the village knows.
No,
apparently they didn't.
But since her,
this girl's aunt was getting pills from [inaudible] uh,
she knew about it,
but everyone of her schoolmates was interested.
One girl said,
I would like to work as she does.
She,
him look at her,
she wears her,
sorry so nicely and goes to different neighborhoods.
My sister told me she earns a good amount of money,
others said,
but my father and grandmother says she's not a good lady.
Shemy Ron said,
grandmothers and fathers are always behind the times.
They do not want to let girls go to school.
I didn't want to consider their opinions.
I like MCHDI Ma's work and I will have pills to control births.
Some girls said,
yes,
I think we should have this medicine,
should we,
so we will not have so many problems with so many children with few children
will be able to keep our saris clean and nice.
Then everybody laughed together and that apparently ended that interview.
So this is uh,
an older generation versus the younger generation.
Uh,
and there's an interest of the girls is they self perceive it and the interest
of the older generation as they are trying to impose it on the younger
generation.
It's a very clear kind of a conflict situation.
The girls see having many children is just causing a lot of problems and what
the girls are instead as not having a lot of children as,
which was terribly important to their,
certainly their grandparents and probably their parents.
They want to have nice clean Saris and,
and,
and look nice.
They want to be able to earn money and go around to different neighborhoods.
And they either the older generation trying to keep them out of school,
keep this information away from them,
et Cetera,
and keep them in the mold,
uh,
previously.
But the girls in that society are pretty much powerless because,
uh,
even though the,
the agent marriage has risen shemy Ron's already 18,
which traditionally is terribly old for girl to be on married,
she will eventually get married,
move in with her husband and the husband will also be a teenager probably.
And we'll have not say much in the,
the husband's mother will be the arbiter of,
of medical things,
reproductive things so that both the son and the daughter in law will be under
the control primarily of the mother-in-law.
And so it's the mother-in-law's opinions that count the mother-in-law's attitude
toward reproduction.
That counts very often.
Uh,
we in the west say that it's the,
it's the problem is all with men that near the Macho men,
uh,
for swimming it to having children.
And some of that is certainly true.
And sometimes in Latin America,
a fair amount of that can be true.
But in,
in Asia,
it's very often the mother-in-law,
wherever you see that,
the young girl to get married young,
the husband and wife are both young.
They move into the husband's house,
which is the grandparents house.
Then the boy will be under control of his mother and the new wife will be
perhaps almost a slave to that mother.
And so you have many,
many instances where both the boy and the husband and the young girl wife do not
want to have children,
but they don't have any choice.
So in matters of reproduction,
it's mother-in-law's who the dominant transmitters of,
of,
of culture and the thing in the world.
So I showed you in the data at the beginning of last lecture that the Shammy
runs of the earth who are not so enamored of having a lot of children have taken
over from the Tetons of the earth who will have as many as,
as they're going to have.
And the data was,
was very strong.
That women in the developing countries,
uh,
don't want all the children that they're currently having.
And you've seen new data and you've seen old data from that.
I showed you Bolivia,
new data.
You could,
I can,
you can come up to my office and see the demographic and health surveys and pick
a country and it's pretty much all the same with the exceptions of sub Saharan
Africa is someone exception.
And some of the Arab countries,
not the Muslim countries,
many Muslim countries have really reduced their fertility but Arab countries are
going through uh,
a nonstandard situation.
This information has been,
God has,
we've had this since about the 1960s.
We had it for about a half a century knowledge that,
that,
that women in the developing world don't really want the children that they're
having in 1960.
And uh,
they started with a surveys called kap knowledge,
attitude,
practice knowledge.
Did you know about contraception attitude?
What do you,
do you want it,
what do you think about it and practice?
Are you actually using it?
And then from 1972 to 82,
there were,
uh,
a survey is called the world fertility survey,
which were improved from that,
from the K P surveys.
And they reached 62 countries with 350,000 women interviewed.
And then from 1985,
they've been coming on with,
uh,
these demographic and health surveys,
which are more or less standardized across the world and from which the data I
gave you came.
And so if you listen to the verbal report of these women,
they say they don't want,
uh,
these children.
But the question you have to always question,
you know,
scientists question everything,
okay,
they say that,
but how much oomph is behind it?
It could be,
you know,
an interviewer comes in,
obviously a very modern person,
you know,
that modern people sort of think that,
that the modern way is to have fewer children.
So you may very well answer them in that way.
So you can never be sure of the servers.
You always have to look at what are people actually doing.
And,
uh,
there were various ways that you can find out if this is a real,
a desire backed by,
by behavior.
And one of the things as well,
how permanent,
if,
if of those women that choose some sort of a family planning method,
uh,
how permanent is it?
How,
how,
how good is it?
And it turns out that basically everywhere in the world,
sterilization is the dominant choice of,
of family planning.
And in Brazil,
uh,
friends in the late by the late 1980s and their facility has come down from
them,
40% of married women using contraception in fact chose to,
uh,
to be sterilized over all the other methods.
Now,
you might think that this was the poorest women who chose this,
that they were kind of desperate.
Maybe they were influenced by family planning workers to just get it over with.
Uh,
and I've heard polemical arguments saying that,
oh,
these sterilization things,
because that was what was pushed upon them by some family planning program.
But in fact,
uh,
to Sussex are very clear that the higher the income level of the woman,
the greater likelihood that she was to choose a sterilization.
Uh,
one of these,
have any of you seen this?
This feeling about the testing of the birth control pill in Puerto Rico called
[inaudible]?
It's sort of a far feminist thing but very shown,
very frequently claiming.
So the birth,
one of the places that the birth control pill from invented America was tested
was in Puerto Rico and it shows a lot of people and they're talking in Spanish,
but there's a narrator speaking in English,
which most everybody can understand.
And s and the narrator is saying how terrible everything is that these women
weren't told what was going on,
blah,
blah.
And what you see when the narrator is speaking is an older woman who wasn't
eligible to be a subject in the test at night climbing into the window at the
basement of the hospital to get the birth control pill.
And the narrator says nothing about that,
but they're showing this to you.
Have you seen it or no?
I saw you had sort of a hand up in the U S so among African educated women that
nobody has presumably pushing around.
Um,
13.8 million.
This is a,
a million women use Tubal ligation of female form of sterilization as their
method of birth control.
And less than that 13.2 million,
we're using the birth control pill.
So in the United States,
like in almost every other country,
sterilization is the chosen means.
And uh,
I think that's one indicator that when people say they want a reduced fertility,
they,
they really mean it.
Sometimes,
uh,
family planning contraception is not available and then people can get into very
desperate situations.
So
an American,
a maternity nurse,
uh,
went to Lusaka,
Zambia,
and this is the university teaching hospital in Zambia.
So most of these developed countries will have a capital city and they have one
high class hospital.
It'll usually being attached to a university.
And that's demanded by the upper class of that country,
the political elite,
the economic elite demand,
good modern medical service.
It will be one hospital there.
And you can look at the uh,
the,
the public health budget for these countries in a very disproportionate amount
of it will go to this one hospital.
So this university teaching hospital in Lusaka is the high level hospital in
Zambia.
And this nurse went into the maternity ward.
She's a maternity nurse expecting to see a lot of women having children.
But instead,
this is what this is her report.
10 women with botched abortions were lying on nine beds,
five others were sprawled on the concrete floors of the hallways,
a few more on the whole,
on the floor,
outside the entrance.
There were no blankets or covers most wait 12 hours for treatment from a
physician.
The quote average woman ends up overnight on the floor.
She receives no food or water.
The women were boarding on the,
on the floors or on their way to the single toilet.
At the end of the long haul,
30% of the patients complete their abortions on the concrete floor with no
medical care.
All we can do is clean it up.
That's the head nurse there said that all we can do is clean it up.
And this is not isolated to this one hospital.
You go anywhere in the underdeveloped world and at least half the beds in
maternity wards are taken up with botched abortions.
And what goes on is in most of African,
a lot of the world abortionist illegal so doctors can't do it.
So they go into or in call Bush doctors,
but some very poorly trained midwife or someone who just says they'll do it and
they have this operation.
And usually something is,
is uh,
put up a stick or coat hanger or something up to the uterus and they tried to
scrape out the fetus.
But in fact,
they often puncture the uterus,
which allows infection to get into the main body cavity.
And then after a few days,
uh,
the,
they're getting very sick from the infection then,
which is now systemic because it's inside the body.
Uh,
plus the wound doesn't heal because of the infection.
So there's constant bleeding and they can lead out huge death rates.
We're going to talk about abortion later and I'll give you some of these
numbers,
but huge death rates.
The important point for this course is that probably all of these women know a,
of someone else who has died from one of these.
And so we call them unprofessional,
uh,
abortions.
And um,
and yet when they get pregnant,
their desire not to have an x child is so strong that they will themselves
choose to undergo this very,
very,
uh,
serious operation with a very high,
a threat of death.
And what's one of the things that,
uh,
the planned parenthood federation and its international efforts like what you
saw is trying to cure and they went to Canada.
They had one project to go to Kenya to train a local private doctors who
somewhat escape the law in family planning and abortion services.
And the local doctors had been turning away,
uh,
abortion clients cause they did not know where to refer them.
So that means they got,
uh,
some unskilled,
practitioner.
One physician told the project director and then he had turned away a young girl
only to find her in a hospital.
A few days later after she had procured an illegal abortion,
the girl died.
The private doctors said that he had since then lived with a great deal of
guilt.
He's happy now that he can provide treatment using a very safe procedure they've
lead and then they,
in between that they've legalized things.
Uh,
to some degree in Kenya,
it's not only the third world in which this takes place in Bulgaria,
uh,
sometime back under the Soviet system,
57% of pregnancies ended in abortion.
You'll hear during the abortion lecture in the United States,
one,
there's one abortion for every three live births and something like 40 to 50
million abortions worldwide.
And about half of these are illegal and illegal means a very unsafe and a woman
dies about every three minutes from a batch to one of these illegal abortions.
So I think with the stories and the large numbers that attached to them in any
woman in that situation that has an abortion,
she does not want that child.
And when you say there's 50 million of them worldwide,
that means that the demand for control of fertility is very,
very,
very high.
You'll read,
uh,
the Brazilian solution to this,
which is a modern form of infanticide.
I don't know if you read yet the death without weeping.
It's in your reading packet where mothers who know that they can't raise a child
just leave the child to die,
and they say that God can take better care of it than I can and,
uh,
they just let the child die.
So this is not to say that.
So what has happened in the world is that fertility has come down drastically.
And I,
and I've,
I've,
I've showed you that in,
in previous graphs where the fertility is coming down and in the peak period,
uh,
and Bolivia,
during the period 20,
the number doubled from about 12% to 25% of people using a modern method.
Ecuador,
50% of the women are using a modern mech mechanism.
Uh,
Tunisia 60%.
And Iran is one of the really interesting cases.
So Iran had this,
uh,
very conservative government and they were against family planning and all this.
And then they had the war with Iraq,
Iraq invaded with the u s help and huge numbers of people died,
including a lot of kids.
So afterwards there,
there young people are depleted.
But once those kids,
they're the recovered a little bit from that.
The government realized what was happening and decided on a family planning
program.
And this is an Iranian woman packing condoms and they're now,
we have this image of places like Iran is being,
you know,
so backwards and conservative and everything.
But they have in fact now one of the best family planning programs in the world
and the UN a few years ago awarded it their top,
top best program in the,
in,
in the world.
And their fertility rate is now at replacement level.
So fertility is,
uh,
coming down,
almost everywhere with again,
Subsaharan Africa and some of the Arab countries as an example.
And birth rates,
not only in birth rates fell Thailand 50% in 12 years.
Columbia 40% in 14 years is at the peak of Indonesia,
48% 20 years,
Morocco,
31% in 12 years.
Turkey,
21% in 10 years.
Brazil,
60% and 25 years.
Mexico,
30% in just six years.
Botswana,
26%.
Zimbabwe,
18% Kenya,
35%.
I mean everywhere that you look,
the actual fertility is coming down.
So people are using contraception and using it
efficiently and the world birth rate has come down quite significantly.
So none of this is to minimize that.
Uh,
people in developing countries are caught in a bind that you all have heard,
all kinds of reasons why they might want to have a lot of children.
And one is extra farm labor.
Uh,
one is support for children and old age or a major kind of problem when their
religion might demand it,
uh,
to cultural reasons,
the various ancestor worship reasons.
So in India you have to have a son to like the funeral pyre.
No son,
you don't go into the afterworld,
uh,
properly.
We discussed some of this with respect to Africa,
a status reasons,
uh,
you have more children,
you have more prestige for both the man and the woman is much a reasons to prove
your fertility.
And the list goes on and on and the reasons they may not use birth control or
many,
one of which is,
uh,
planning family planning services can be very primitive.
There's not a great slide,
but it's an old bus in India,
the Red Cross on it.
And this is the family planning clinic,
uh,
in this part of India at this time.
And you know,
people were supposed to go on this bus and have some operation that they didn't
understand,
a done to them,
sterilization or a IUD insertion or something and you know,
you wouldn't be exactly very anxious to get on to that,
to that bus.
Um,
another thing that I mentioned last time with respect specter,
uh,
Vinas lecture that the worry about medical complications is one of the most
major reasons why women either don't use contraception all or start it and then
stop using it.
And what does this mean in a premedical country where they don't have really
modern medical ideas?
You take the pill,
you're scared of it.
Anything that happens to you,
you get a tummy ache,
you fall and break your leg,
you know,
anything that happens to you,
what do you blame?
You blame the pill.
So here is a culture without much medicine at a low standard of living,
they're getting sick.
A lot.
People in developing countries are not generally very healthy and they get sick
and they don't know what to closet by.
You probably read already about the evil lie.
Now did you read the Egyptian,
the coalcoholic yet the evil eye is the reason.
If you've taken the pill,
you know,
that's changing your body in some way and you're afraid of it.
You get sick with anything.
It's the pill was the reason for it.
And then you tell all your friends that and everybody in the community learns
that such and such got some problem because of the pill.
So they're very much afraid,
uh,
to use the pill and uh,
on,
on and on.
That's a big conflict contest station.
The media,
I think this is,
uh,
in Morocco,
this is a cave.
Whoops.
One that doesn't project very well,
but the wide open,
you can see it's a cave.
This is the desert around here.
They're in the cage.
And what they're watching is the TV show.
And I was in Morocco in the far desert.
And you see these little villages have just a few mud houses and they all had
solar arrays and they all had television.
So media is passing on very strongly.
Uh,
on the other side of the question is all kinds of reasons that they don't use it
or that they do do use it.
It's a very much in contestation
in the West,
uh,
especially activists,
liberal people,
people in the forestry school believe that,
you know,
we shouldn't support family planning programs because it's politically,
it's politically contentious.
And why is it politically contentious?
Because people in the right or opposed to it for religious or more regions,
people on more or less left.
And these are characterizations right and left,
you know,
we can't impose,
we great white Westerners can impose our values on our poor,
little yellow and brown,
uh,
cousins.
And it's utter nonsense.
And,
and it's,
it's,
it's patronizing because the people in these developing countries has spoken
very clearly when they add up all these pluses and minuses,
that's,
that's their,
their,
their choice.
And as I've showed your data,
not hit you over the head with data showing you that when people in the
developing countries themselves add up the data,
they want to be protected from contraception.
And I think that we in the west,
or to take that very seriously and starting with intellectuals who should know
better.
But since people don't give courses like this and people,
even environmentalist and all kinds of others just don't pay any attention to
human population,
uh,
because it's politically untouchable.
The major organizations,
the environmental organizations won't touch it because they do fundraising.
And the public opinion is that,
oh,
it's a horrible thing to,
to push family planning on developing countries.
So,
um,
I guess that is where we will end today.
Few,
yes.
One more this week before vacation.